so i want to talk to you about two
things tonight
number one
teaching surgery
and doing surgery is really hard
and second
that language is one of the most
profound things that separate us
all over the world
and in my little corner of the world
these two things are actually related
and i want to tell you how tonight
now
nobody wants an operation who here has
had surgery
did you want it keep your hands up if
you wanted an operation nobody wants an
operation
in particular nobody wants an operation
with tools like these
through large incisions
that cause a lot of pain
that cause a lot of time out of work or
out of school
that leave a big scar
but if you have to have an operation
what you really want is a minimally
invasive operation that's what i want to
talk to you about tonight
how doing and teaching this type of
surgery
led us on a search for a better
universal translator
now this type of surgery is hard
and it starts by putting people to sleep
putting carbon dioxide in their abdomen
blowing them up like a balloon
sticking one of these sharp pointy
things
into their abdomen
dangerous stuff
and taking instruments
and watching it on a tv screen so let's
see what it looks like
so this is gallbladder surgery we
perform a million of these a year in the
united states alone
this is the real thing there's no blood
and you can see how focused the surgeons
are
how much concentration it takes you can
see it in their faces
it's hard to teach
and it's not all that easy to learn
we do about 5 million of these in the
united states and maybe 20 million of
these
worldwide
all right
you've all heard the term he's a born
surgeon
let me tell you surgeons are not born
surgeons are not made either
we have no little tanks where we're
making surgeons
surgeons are trained
one step at a time
it starts with a foundation
basic skills
we build on that and we take people
hopefully
to the operating room where they learn
to be an assistant then we teach them to
be a surgeon in training
and when they do all of that for about
five years they get the coveted board
certification
if you need surgery you want to be
operated on by a board-certified surgeon
you get your board certificate and you
can go out into practice
and eventually if you're lucky you
achieve mastery
now that foundation is so important
that
a number of us from the largest general
surgery society in the united states
sages
started in the late 1990s a training
program that would assure
that every surgeon who practices
minimally invasive surgery would have a
strong foundation of knowledge
and skills
necessary to go on and do procedures
now the science behind this
is so potent
that it became required by the american
board of surgery in order for a young
surgeon to become board certified
it's not a lecture
it's not a course
it's all of that
plus a high stakes assessment
it's hard
now
just this past year
one of our partners the american college
of surgeons
teamed up with us to make an
announcement that all surgeons
should be fls certified
before they do minimally invasive
surgery
and are we talking about just people
here in the u.s and canada
no we just said all surgeons
so to lift
this education and training
worldwide is a very large task something
i'm very personally excited about
as we travel around the world sages does
surgery all over the world teaching and
educating surgeons
so we have a problem and one of the
problems is distance
we can't travel everywhere
we need to make the world a smaller
place
and i think that we can develop some
tools to do so and one of the tools i
like personally
is using video
so i was inspired by a friend this is
alan acronic from toronto
and he proved
that you could actually teach people
to do surgery
using video conferencing so here's alan
teaching an english speaking surgeon in
africa
these basic fundamental skills necessary
to do minimally invasive surgery very
inspiring
but for this examination which is really
hard
we have a problem
even people who say they speak english
only 14 pass
because for them it's not a surgery test
it's an english test
let me bring it to you locally
i work at the cambridge hospital
it's a primary harvard medical school
teaching facility
we have more than a hundred translators
covering 63 languages
and we spend millions of dollars
just in our little hospital
it's a big labor intensive effort
if you think about the worldwide burden
of trying to talk to your patients not
just teaching surgeons just trying to
talk to your patients
there aren't enough translators in the
world
we need to employ technology
to assist us in this quest
at our hospital we see everybody from
harvard professors to people who just
got here last week
and you have no idea how hard it is to
talk to somebody or take care of
somebody you can't talk to
and there isn't always a translator
available so we need tools
we need a universal translator
one of the things that i want to leave
you with
as you think about this talk
is that this talk is not just about us
preaching to the world
it's really about setting up a dialogue
we have a lot to learn
here in the united states we spend more
money
per person for outcomes that are not
better than many countries in the world
maybe we have something to learn as well
so i'm passionate about teaching these
fls skills all over the world this past
year i've been in latin america i've
been in china
talking about fundamentals of
laparoscopic surgery
and everywhere i go
the barrier is we want this
but we need it in our language
so here's what we think we want to do
imagine giving a lecture
and being able to talk to people in
their own native language simultaneously
i want to talk to the people in asia
latin america africa europe
seamlessly
accurately
and in a cost-effective fashion using
technology
and it has to be bi-directional they
have to be able to teach us something as
well
it's a big task
so we looked for a universal translator
i thought there would be one out there
your web page has translation your cell
phone has translation
but nothing that's good enough
to teach
surgery
because we need a lexicon what is a
lexicon a lexicon is a body of words
that describes a domain
i need to have a healthcare lexicon
and in that i need a surgery lexicon
that's a tall order
we have to work at it so let me show you
what we're doing
this is research can't buy it
we're working with the folks at ibm
research from the accessibility center
to string together technologies to work
towards the universal translator
it starts with a framework system
where the surgeon delivers the lecture
using a framework of captioning
technology
we then add another technology to do
video conferencing
but we don't have the words yet so we
add a third technology
and now we've got the words
and we can apply the special sauce
the translation
we get the words up in a window
and then apply the magic we work with
the fourth technology
and we're currently have access to 11
language pairs
more to come
as we
think about trying to make the world a
smaller place
and i'd like to show you our prototype
of stringing all of these technologies
that don't necessarily always talk to
each other to become something useful
fundamentals of laparoscopic surgery
module 5 manual skills practice
students may display captions
in their native language
if you're in latin america you click i
want it in spanish button
and alpha comes in real time in spanish
but if you happen to be sitting in
beijing at the same time by using
technology in a constructive fashion
you could get it in mandarin or you
could get it in russian
on and on and on simultaneously without
the use of human translators
but that's the lectures if you remember
what i told you about fls at the
beginning it's knowledge
and skills
the difference in an operation between
doing something successfully
and not maybe moving your hand this much
so we're going to take it one step
further we brought my friend alan back
today we're going to practice suturing
this is how you hold the needle
grab the needle at the tip
it's important to be accurate
aim for the black dots
orient your loop this way
and i'll go ahead and cut
very good oscar
i'll see you next week
so that's what we're working on
in our quest for the universal
translator
we want it to be bi-directional
we have a need to learn as well as to
teach
i can think of a million uses for a tool
like this
as we think about intersecting
technologies everybody has a cell phone
with a camera
we could use this everywhere whether it
be healthcare
patient care
engineering law conferencing translating
videos
this is ubiquitous tool
in order to break down our barriers we
have to learn to talk to people
to demand
that people work on translation
we need it for our everyday life
in order to make the world a smaller
place
thank you very much